RESOURCES IN WATER WILL COME TO
ORDER. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS A-
FROM NEAR AND FAR AND IN
RESPONSETHE CLOVER NINETEEN
EMERGENCY IN TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC SENATORS AND SENATE
STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS- AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE WILL BE HOLDING AN
ESSENTIAL HERE AND HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS NORMAL
PRACTICE. ORDERED PUBLIC.
ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WHILE CONDUCTING THE
HEARING IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE-
PUBLIC AND OUR EMPLOYEES. AS WE
COMPLY WITH THOSE ORDERS WERE
HOLDING COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE
IN THE CAPITAL. I WITH ONE OF
THE ARE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING IN DEBATE
REMOTELY WITH THE USE OF VIDEO
CONFERENCE SYSTEM. FOR MEMBERS
WHO WILL BE ATTENDING REMOTE
TODAY PLEASE MEET YOUR.
IN THE
BILL NUMBER TO WHICH YOU ARE
REFERRING. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF PUBLIC. TWO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLICCOMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT HERE IN JUST A MOMENT.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
1-844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SIX ZERO SEVEN ONE
ZERO THREE TWO. WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT A MODERATOR
WILL IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY
OPEN YOUR LINE AT THAT TIME YOU
MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACKYOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOUR
WATCHING HEARING ON PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR
FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
THE CORN DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE HEARING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE
STREAMLINED HEARING PROCESSING
CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE
TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE JESTING TO THE USE OR NEW-
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES SO
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL IMPATIENT.
SO THAT ALL INTERESTED PARTIES
CAN BE HEARD. MEMBERS WE HAVE
SIX BILLS ON THE AGENDA FOR
TODAY- BUT BEFORE YOU HEAR
PRESENTATION ON BILLS LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. CHIEF
CONSULTANT WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AND MEMBERS- JUST
REMEMBER- PUT YOUR MIKES ON TO.
TO RESPOND. STERN TURN HERE
JONES JONES HERE ALLEN. ALLEN
HERE COME EUROPE PRESENT
CARRIER-PRESENTHERTZBERG YOUR
THIRD BURKE HERE HUESO HERE
HERTZBERG HERE HERE JACK. MY
HERE MONNING HERE WE HAVE A
FOUR OKAY VERY GOOD- SEEING
THAT WE NOW HAVE A QUORUM I I'D
ALSO LIKE TO RECOGNIZE OUR
MEMBERS WHO IS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY FROM HIS DISTRICT
OFFICE- CENTER BOARD JUST-
WELCOME AND THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
A- THERE WILL BE PARTICIPATION
COMMENTS QUESTIONS AND DEBATE
TODAY BUT- SIR WERE JUST WON'T
BE VOTING- LET'S START WITH
THEIR CONSENT CALENDAR A WE
HAVE THREE BILLS A PROPOSED CAN
ENCOUNTER MEMBERS WE HAVE FILE.
NUMBER TWO SB TWELVE ONE MON
FILE ITEM FIVE THAT SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY TWO WHICH IS OUR
COMMITTEE BILL AND THEN FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX AS CHAIR
FOURTEEN SENATOR ARE TO LET
THAT DOES ANYONE TO REMOVE THE
MEASURE FROM KAY. AND OUR
MOTION THAT ARE RIGHT MOTIONS
OUR BY CHAIR. CHIEF AND YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL IN THE CAN
CALENDAR OKAY THE MOST IS TO A
CAN CAL FILE ITEMS TOO FIVE IN
SIX STERN HI TURN ALL RIGHT
JONES HI JONES HI ALAN. OUR ON
A COPIER I. DOUBLE ZERO HI
HURTS. THIRD HIGHWAYS. HUESO
AYE JACKSON MON NINE MONNING HI
THE BILL. SAID THE SEVEN VOTES
IT'S OUT OKAY SEVEN THAT THE
CALENDAR ADULT. I BELIEVE WE'RE
GOING IN FILE ORDER THE MORNING
SO. SENATOR TOM DOES NOT IS
STILL VERY GOOD WELCOME COME ON
UP. THERE TEND TO. FOR THE
SWITCH A ROO ME. GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU MISTER TURN MEMBERS
OUT TODAY I'M HERE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL TEN TWELVE WHICH IS
THAT WHICH IS A PROGRAM FOR THE
PLUGIN AND ABANDON OF HAZARDOUS
FOR IDLE DESERTED WELLS AND D.
COMMISSIONS ASSOCIATED FACILITY
FACILITIES IN THE SOUTHERN
VALLEY. SOUTHERN CENTRAL
VALLEY. EARLY THIS YEAR I SAT
WITH MY CONSTITUENTS IN KERN
COUNTY WHO RAISE OUR CONCERNS
ABOUT THE LACK OF RESOURCES IN
OUR REGION. LOCAL LEADERS AND
ADVOCATES SHARED THEIR STORIES
ABOUT HOW UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES CONTINUE TO BE
NEGLECTED WHEN IT COMES TO
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION JOBS
AND MORE. HELLO SEE IN NOVEMBER
OF TWENTY IN KERN FACE SIX
POINT PER AND- THAT'S TWENTY
FOUR THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
PEOPLE AND THIS IS AT A TIME
WHEN CALIFORNIA ENJOYED A THREE
POINT 7% UNEMPLOYMENT RATE.
WITH SOME REGULATORY CHALLENGES
THAT NUMBER ROSE TO NINE POINT
1% IN FEBRUARY OF THIS YEAR.
THAT TOGETHER WITH COLBERT
NINETEEN IT FOR THE ROSE 212%
NOW IT FORTY SIX THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED PEOPLE FOR ON.
UNEMPLOYMENT SOME RURAL
COMMUNITIES IN THE COUNTY FACE
ARE IN AN EMPLOYMENT TRADE OF
AS HIGH AS 26% WHAT WE SAT DOWN
WITH STAKEHOLDERS ACROSS THE
BOARD FROM ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS
TRIPS AND TO INDUSTRY AND
FAMILIES WHO WERE BORN AND
RAISED IN KERN COUNTY. WE HAVE
HONEST CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW
TO TACKLE ONE THING. THE PUBLIC
HEALTH OF OUR COMMUNITIES. IN
ADDITION TO OUR CONVERSATIONS
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY REPORTED
THAT THERE ARE OVER TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACTIVE AND IDLE OIL
AND GAS ALL THE CALIFORNIA.
THIS INCLUDES FIVE THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED FORTY WELLS THAT
MAY HAVE NO VIABLE OPERATE OR
ARE AT RISK OF BECOMING
ORPHANED IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
THESE IDLE AN ORPHAN WELLS CAN
RELEASE TALK TOXIC MISSIONS TO
THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES
CREATING HEALTH CONCERNS FOR
OUR CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
WITHIN THAT AREA. TODAY AS WE
ARE FACING THE WORLD HEALTH
CRISIS TOGETHER DO TO COPE IN
NINETEEN THE INITIAL STE THE
ISSUES DOLLARS OVER THE
COMMUNITIES OF KERN COUNTY.
THAT THE PROBLEM. THE CARD IS
SB FORTY FIVE A SENATOR JACK.
WHICH ALREADY ADDRESSES SIMILAR
ISSUE SECURING FUNDS FOR CLEAN
NEVER. WELLS OUT SB FORTY FORTY
NOT. ED DO ENOUGH FOR THE
REGION OF CURRENT AT THE PART
TO CAL. COASTAL RE. AS TEN OVER.
CAL JUMPED PRIOR TO PUBLIC THE
PARK. WILL TAKING. STEPS TO
RECOVER PLUGGING ABANDONMENT
COST ASSOCIATE WITH. THE DE
COMMISSIONING ATTENDED
FACILITIES FROM OPERATORS WHO
HAVE NOT REPORTED ACTIVE
OPERATIONS LAST FIVE YEARS. SB
TEN TWELVE ALSO REQUIRES CAL
JIM TO INCLUDE IN THEIR ANNUAL
REPORT AN UPDATE TO THE
LEGISLATURE WHICH INCLUDE
SPECIFIC LOCATIONS OF
APPLICABLES WELLS AND
FAILITIES. THE REGISTERED
OPERATOR AND WHETHER THE
OPERATORS ARE COMPLYING WITH
CALIFORNIA LAW. TODAY HAVE
THREE WITNESSES JOINING US
REMOTELY HE LIKE RCA
REPRESENTING WEST BY. SEAN
WALKED REPRESENTING STEP BACK
AND TED KORD. WITH IAN BE
RESOURCE. VERY GOOD AT YOU
SENATOR PRESS. WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO. YOUR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT-
DUE TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
THE LINKS OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
NEW CLEANING PROTOCOLS
COMMITTEES WILL INSTITUTE TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY ACCORDINGLY
EACH SIDE WILL ONLY BE
PERMITTED TOTAL THREE MINUTES.
ALL OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS THIS NAME-
TO THEIR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE MEASURES- SO-
LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE. PRESENT. RIGHT ON THE
PHONE LINE UNDERSTOOD THANK YOU.
SO SEEING NO WITNESSES IN IN
THE ROOM HERE IN FORTY TWO OR
THREE ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY WHICH TO
pTHANK YOU- WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE SERVICE. AND
I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE THREE
WITNESSES ALL OF WHOM ARE ON
THE LINE- MODERATE IF YOU
PLEASE PROP THE INDIVIDUALS
WITHIN TESTIFIED SUPPORT WILL
BEGIN. WE DO HAVE TED CORDOVA
SHAUN MULLEN TIENEN EASILY
GARCIA YOUR LINES ARE OPEN.
THANK YOU GET MORE NUMBER OF MY
COMING THAT THIS WALL IN TIME
FROM THE CALIFORNIA PETROLEUM.
GOOD MORNING PLEASE PROCEED
GOOD MORNING YES WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF BUT SENATE BILL TEN
TWELVE- THE BILL EMPATHIZES
BINDING AND PROPER REMAIN WORK
AND OIL WELL. OUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL IT'S CONSISTENT WITH
OUR ONGOING COMPLY WITH
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TO NINE
TWENTY. WHICH REQUIRE OIL
PRODUCER TO SHRINK THERE IN THE
OF IDLE BY KIDS 6% ANNUALLY.
MEMBERS FULLY INVESTED IN MAINE
IDLE WELL MAY PLANNED FOR
SKINNER WITH CAL. TO MEET
HIGHEST ORANGE I'LL WELL IN OUR
IN THE ARE PROPERLY ACCOUNT FOR
TEST. AND EVENTUALLY PROP THE
COMMISSION. THERE ARE ON A
QUEST OF WHETHER THE ARE LAR
NUMBER OR WELL IN CALIFORNIA
OIL THE NO LONGER HAVE A BY
OWNER. THIS BILL WOULD HELP
WITH ALL THE QUEST. TO BE CLEAR.
THE WAY THIS BILL WIDE ENOUGH I
DO NOT BELONG TO THEM OF OUR
TRADE NATION. BY WAY EVERY MINE
IN. HEY ONE HOW PERCENT OF THE-
OF READING MORE WHILE ACT
THERE'S YOU WHAT THE BILL OR HE
CAN MEASURE WORKING WELL AND
YOU'RE NOT HAVE THAT DO NOT
HAVE A- OWNER. WE'LL INDUSTRY
FUND 1% THE CALL. CAL JIM HAS
PLUG WELL OVER TO THE WELL OVER
THE SEVERAL DECADES. USING FROM
BY ORAL. AND CLOSE. IT'S IN THE
BEST INTEREST THE STATE AND OIL
PRODUCED TO IN THAT ALL WEALTH
IN THE STATE. ARE PROPERLY IT
FOR AND PROPERLY MANAGED AT ALL
TIMES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
ARRIVAL. SENATORS EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS RAISED BY
HER CONSTITUENTS. IN HER
COMMUNITY EARLIER THIS YEAR. SB
TEN TWELVE WOULD COMPLEMENT
RECENTLY ADOPTED LEGISLATION BY
ENSURING THAT WELLS REGISTERED
TO AN OPERATOR. BUT DOES NOT
HAVE AN ACTIVE IDYLLWILD
MANAGEMENT PLAN OR A VITAL
WEALTHY. ENSURING THAT ALL NOT
WELL COULD NOT BECOME A ALLY TO
THE STATE AND LOCAL. BUY EXTRA
IMPORTANT ITEMS THAT BECAUSE.
TWELVE WELL ENABLE DIVISION
DIRECTLY ADDRESS THE OF PARTY
WILL TO DENTIST BY. MY LOOK YOU
SEE THAT'S THE RIVER. SENATOR
MENTIONED EARLIER. ALL UP OF
OIL GAS WELLS ARE RESPONSE TO
SAFELY WITH OR- AT THE END OF
THEIR PRODUCTIVE. WHICH ANSWER
FOR MEMBERS IN THE SCRIPT. IN A
WORK. WITH THE LETTUCE. ON PRE
PLEDGES. TO ENSURE THAT. SB TEN
TWELVE IS THE- TO THE CAR A
CRIME. AND WILL ENSURE THAT ALL
OPERATE LIVE UP THE SAME.
REPRESENTING THE IN THE NATURAL
RESOURCES IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL TEN TWELVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE OPEN LINES
AND. SO WE CAN HEAR FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS. LET'S TURN TO THE
OTHER PORTION LYING. ABSOLUTELY
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN FOR ALL
WHO WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT IN
FAVOR OF SB TEN TWELVE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT IN FAVOR OF SB TEN
TWELVE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
AND NINE THIRTY ONE IF I MAY
HAVE YOU. PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD NINE
THIRTY ONE. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AS PAUL YOUR ON BEHALF OF THE
KERN COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF TEN
TWELVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT. OF SB TEN
TWELVE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF
TEN TWELVE VERY GOOD THANK YOU
MODERATOR. SINGER NO MORE
WITNESSES. IF YOU PLEASE OPEN
LINES IN CALL THE OPPOSITION.
TESTIFY IF THERE ANY. THANK YOU
AND ALL OF THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF SB
TEN TWELVE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TEN TWELVE.
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE
HAVE NO COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE.
THREE GOOD IN SEEING THOUGH-
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY OR IN OUR PRESENT
HEARING ROOM CHECKING ONCE
AGAIN. SEEING WILL BRING IT
BACK TO DISCUSSION TO THE
MEMBERS QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
AMONG THE- MOTION FROM SENATOR
HUESO- CENTER TITLE I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE A BRIEF COMMENT
I APPRECIATE. THE HARD WORK
YOU'VE BEEN DOING BACK HOME AND
REALLY TO GET INTO- I'D VERY
COMPLICATED AND INTIMATE
PROBLEM THAT IT AFFECTS PEOPLE-
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE GO TO WORK
EVERY DAY- IN IN THIS INDUSTRY
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE LIVE IN THE
SAME PLACE THAT THEY WORK AND
ARE GOING THROUGH THEIR OWN. I
CHALLENGES- OVER THE YEARS
APPRECIATE THE GOALS OF THE
BILL AND- YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT THIS THIS WORKING
WELL ISSUE FOR A WHILE WE HELD
AN OVERSIGHT HEARING AND- GOT
INTO SOME OF THOSE ISSUES- I
SHE- SOME OF THE CONCERNS YOU
EXPRESSED ABOUT- THOSE WHO
REALLY DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY
TO DO THAT- IDOLING AND
ABANDONING THEMSELVES. I WILL
SAY AT THIS MOMENT I AM A
LITTLE DISAPPOINTED IN OUR
FRIENDS IN THE INDUSTRY- ARE
THE LEAD WITNESSES I WOULD.
THAT AT SOME POINT APPRECIATE.
THE WRIST RESPONSE TO HOW THEY
THINK WE'LL GET THIS DONE NOW
THAT WE'VE CUT THE BUDGET OF
CAL JAM OUT PER THEIR REQUEST-
SO I AM CONCERNED ABOUT SOME OF
THE- SOME OF THE ONGOING BUDGET
ISSUES THAT- WE JUST SAW.
MATERIALIZE THIS WEEK I HOPE WE
CAN FIND THE ABILITY WITHIN
INDUSTRY TO GET THIS WORK DONE
BUT IT A TIME WHEN. THE GLOBAL
VOLATILITY IN THE OIL MARKET IS
REALLY WHIP SAWING OUR LOCAL
ECONOMIES. WE HAVE AN INDUSTRY
ITSELF IS IN FLUX- AND- GIVEN
THAT THE WHOLE STRUCTURE OF THE
CLEAN UP PROCESS IS REALLY
CONTINGENT ON THEIR ABILITY TO
KEEP THEIR BALANCE SHEET STRONG
AND STATE. VIABLE AND LARGE
ENOUGH TO HANDLE ALL THESE.
ORPHAN WELLS THEY'RE ALL OVER
LA TO AN ALL OVER THE STATE IF
THEY GO. AWAY THEN WE REALLY
WE HAVE OUR HEADS WRAPPED
AROUND THAT CHALLENGE SO I
WELCOME THE INPUT FROM- ALL
STAKEHOLDERS FRANKLY AND HOW WE
MARSHALL. THE SOME PLAN TO
AVOID A MULTI HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR LIABILITY IN IN
ACCORDING TO THE REPORTS WE'VE
BEEN SEEING HERE- BUT WHAT I
WILL SAY CENTER TIDY YOU'RE
MAKING AN EFFORT IN THAT REGARD
TO REALLY MAKE PROGRESS- AND I
APPRECIATE THE WORK YOU'VE DONE
HERE. SO I'M GONNA BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL- AND I
WOULD WELCOME ANY FINAL CLOSING
REMARKS YOU MIGHT BE WILLING TO
MAKE. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IT YOU'RE
ABLE OKAY THANK YOU- AS WE HAVE
A MOTION FROM CENTER HUESO. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS. THE HELLO
LET'S CALL THE ROLL CHIEF
CONSULTANT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS STERN HI
TURN ON A JONES I JONES ON A
ALLEN. ALLEN ALL RIGHT COME
BUREAU. HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
HIGHWAY SO HUESO ALL RIGHT
MONNING AYE MONNING BY. SIX
ZERO OKAY WORDS SIX ZERO- THAT
BILL IS OUT BUT WE WILL LEAVE
IT ON CALL FOR THE REMAINING
MEMBERS THANK YOU CENTER TIED
UP NEXT. I BELIEVE- SENATOR
ALSO WAITING PATIENTLY SB
TWELVE NINETY SIX. THIS IS.
OKAY GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING
A GREAT TO SEE ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES TODAY ACTUALLY SEE
YOU- THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ARE I WANT TO THANK THE
pWONDERFUL- COMPREHENSIVE
ANALYSIS OF THIS BILL AND- WANT
TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS AS
DETAILED ON PAGES SEVEN TO NINE
OF THE ANALYSIS SB TWELVE
NINETY SIX WILL REQUIRE EACH
STATE CONSERVANCY AND THE
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD TO
ESTABLISH GRANT PROGRAMS THAT
TRAIN AND EMPLOYEE INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE HAVE BEEN FACED WITH
BERRIES TO EMIT. THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE HAVE
PROPOSED THREE SEPARATE CLIMATE
RESILIENCE BONDS IN PREPARATION
A CURRENT LONG TERM CLIMATE
IMPACTS THE MAIN PART THESE ARE
WATER WILDFIRE SEA LEVEL RISE
EXTREME HEAT AT COMMUNITY AND
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE EACH
PROPOSAL BERRIES AND
COMMITMENTS TO WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT IN CLIENT
RESILIENCE THE STATE NOW HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ALIGN THE
COULD NOT MAKE AND CLIMATE
GOALS AND PRIORITIZE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT IN THIS. IT COVERT
NINETEEN HAS EXACERBATES
EXACERBATED ECONOMIC HARDSHIPS
ESPECIALLY IN WORKING CLASS
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR THESE ARE THE SAME
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS.
CALIFORNIA'S FOURTH CLIMATE
CHANGE ASSESSMENT HAS PROJECTED
THAT COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
DIRECT CLIMATE IMPACTS BY
TWENTY FIFTEEN OR IN THE ORDER
OF TENS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
SO TO ADDRESS THE ECONOMIC
IMPACTS AND CLIMATE CHANGE THE
STATE MUST INVEST IN HIGH
QUALITY GOOD PAYING JOBS IN THE
GREEN ECONOMY. THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE STATE CONSERVANCY AND
THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD
TO ESTABLISH GRANT PROGRAMS
THAT SET WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
CRITERIA FOR CLIMATE RESILIENCE
PROGRAMS THEY WILL SEEK INPUT
FROM THE STATE AND LOCAL LOCAL
WORKFORCE PARTNERS. TO DEVELOP
CAREER PATHWAYS STRATEGIES IN
THE NATURAL RESOURCES FIELD THE
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD
COVERS AREAS NOT SERVED BY A
CONSERVANCY. AND SB TWELVE
NINETY SIX WOULD PROVIDE THE
HANDS ON EXPERIENCE
CERTIFICATION AND PLACEMENT
SERVICES FOR INDIVIDUALS BUT
AGAIN WHO HAVE NOT HAD THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES AS OTHERS THE
STATE CAN USE EXISTING FUNDS
LIKE THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND. AND THE
ENVIRONMENTAL LICENSE PLATE
FUND AND FUTURE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FUNDS TO INVEST IN
THESE PROGRAMS. FUNDAMENTAL TO
ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND CLAMOR
RESISTANCE IS THE EXPLICIT
INCLUSION A WORKING CLASS
COMMUNITIES AND UNITIES OF
COLORS. BUT WITH THESE
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS THESE MEN
AND WOMEN CAN RECEIVE THE
TRAINING EDUCATION AND
CERTIFICATION PUT THEM ON AN
EQUAL FOOTING SO THEY CAN
PURSUE THESE NATURAL RESOURCES
CAREERS. CALIFORNIA MUST ALIGN
OUR ECONOMIC AND CLIMB A GOALS
AND ENSURE CALIFORNIA'S BENEFIT
FROM THE GREEN ECONOMY FOR
THESE REASONS I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY BRING THIS BEFORE
YOU I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU MEMBERSAND MISTER CHAIR.
MY TWO WITNESSES TODAY WILL BE
FERNANDO GOMEZ BUT THE
MOUNTAINS RECREATION AND
CONSERVATIVE CONSERVATION
AUTHORITY AS THE WOLINSKY FROM
CALAVERAS HELD THE IMPACT
PRODUCT SOLUTIONS. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO- WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO ANYONE WANTING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT WE'VE
BEEN THROUGH THE PROTOCOLS IN
TERMS OF TIMING AND- THE
LIMITATIONS THERE- TURNING
FIRST TO OUR ROOM HERE AND
FORTY TWO OR THREE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. SEEING
NONE WE MOVED TO A ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. SEEING NONE IN TWENTY
FORTY WILL NOT NOW MOVE ON TO
OUR TELECONFERENCE LINE
MODERATE IF YOU PLEASE PROPERTY
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TESTIFIED
SUPPORT. WHEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING I'M RETIRED COUNTY
SUPERVISOR CALAVERAS COUNTY I
SERVED FOR EIGHT YEARS ON THE
MOTHER LODE JOB TRAINING BOARD
AND CALAVERAS MARIPOSA
COMMUNITY ACTION AGENCY. THE
DISTRICT ARE REPRESENTED WAS
ONCE PROSPEROUS WHILE TWENTY
TWO BOMBINO CAME IN ONE. LAST
ONE SHUT DOWN IN TOWN IN TWO
THOUSAND AND THREE IN OUR
COMMUNITY SOCCER THE STATE OF
GRINDING RURAL POVERTY
ADDICTION AND DESPAIR. AT ONE
POINT 98% OF OUR ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL KIDS WERE ELIGIBLE FOR
FREE AND REDUCED LUNCHES. ARE
LOWEST POINT IN TWO THOUSAND
FOUR TRIBAL AN ENVIRONMENTAL
LEADERS JOINED WITH FORMER
LOGGERS MILL WORKERS TO FORM
THE NONPROFIT CHIPS. YOUR
DEDICATED DEVELOPING A
RESURGENT RURAL ECONOMY BASED
UPON FOREST MEADOW CULTURAL
CITING WATERSHED RESTORATION.
AND STEWARDSHIP. WE TRAIN EQUIP
AND DEPLOY CHRONICALLY
UNEMPLOYED LOCAL FUNDS TO DO
THIS WORK THREE QUARTERS OF OUR
LEADERSHIP AND STAFF OF SEVENTY
ARE MEMBERS OF THE NEW LOCK
WASHER AND HOW YOU TRY. THE
WHOLE MULTI YEAR CONTRACTS LOOK
FOR YOU ASKED FOR IT THE BILL
AND GOT SOME THE NATIONAL PARK
FIRE SAFE COUNCILS AND PRIVATE
LANDOWNERS. I'M PLEASED TO
TESTIFY AND SUPPORTED SB TWELVE
NINETY SIX TODAY. SOME OF THE
CHECK NOW. STRIDES STUDIOS AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FACE WHILE
TRYING TO INCREASE THE PRICE
SCALE OF THIS VITAL EFFORTS.
THE CARD IS LOW INCOME AND
COLLECTED COMMUNITIES IN BOTH
URBAN AND RURAL PARTS THE STATE.
YEAH PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE WC
BABY CONSERVING HEARINGS AND
LOCAL PERSONNEL. RECOGNIZED AND
ENCOURAGED IT OPENS THE DOOR TO
GREATER RECRUITMENT AND
TRAINING AND CERTIFICATION OF
THE EMERGING RESTORATION AND
STORAGE OF WORK FOR. WE HEAR
TRYING TO TRANSITION FROM THE
SHORT LIVED RESOURCE EXTRACTION
ECONOMY. ONE BASED ON A
SUSTAINABLE EFFORTS TO RESTORE
OUR LANDSCAPE AND TAKE OUR
RIGHTFUL PLACE AS THE WORDS OF
THE LATE THE LIGHT. THIS BILL
WILL HELP EXPEDITE THIS
EVOLUTION. SB TWELVE NINETY SIX
ALSO ENVISIONED THE FUNDING
STREAM WHICH CAN HELP
FACILITATE CREATION OF A
VERSATILE MULTI SKILLED YEAR
ROUND AND ONLY CERTIFIED
WORKFORCE TO TACKLE THE CLIMATE
CHALLENGES WHILE ENHANCING THE
ECONOMICS OF THE PEOPLE IN
PLACE SO OFTEN WORKED OUT AND
YET MOST LIKELY TO SUFFER THE
CONSEQUENCES OF ENVIRONMENTAL
DEGRADATION. I HOPE YOU'LL FIND
FAVOR WITH THIS EFFORT SO
TWELVE NINETY SIX FORD THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THE NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. IN ALL OF THOSE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT IN FAVOR
OF SB TWELVE NINETY SIX PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND WE DO HAVE MINE THIRTY
SEVEN. ONE MOMENT. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING JAMIE GO ON
BEHALF CAL TROUT AS WELL THE
FEAR IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT WITNESS. NINE THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE MINE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND WE'LL COME BACK TO
LINE THIRTY ONE MOMENT. NINE
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MICHELLE RANTS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT
THANKS VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
NINE THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND SENATORS LUCAS FERRIC SOME
HALF THE NATURE CONSERVANCY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF CENTER
GARAGES SB TWELVE NINETY SIX
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. ONE TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THIS IS FUNNY AND MAKE
PEACE CO FOUNDER AND POLICY
DIRECTOR OF THE NONPROFIT KISS
THE GROUND AND WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF CENTER ON THOSE SB
TWELVE NINETY SIX THANK YOU. TO
TEST MONEY. NEXT. NINE THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING NATALIE MAC FROM HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE LA
NEIGHBORHOOD LAPTOP THE LA
RIVER BUT REGIONAL OKAY THANKS
DISTRICTS THANK YOU FOR ALL IN
ESCONDIDO CREEK CONSERVANCY AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NINE FORTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MRS MORGAN COMMING ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMUNITY NATURE CONNECTION
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LOCAL CONSERVATION CORPS THE
SAN JOSE CONSERVATION CORPS AND
SAVE THE REDWOODS LEAGUE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MUCH. ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS IN FAVOR OF
SB TWELVE NINETY SIX PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
NINE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I MEAN I KNOW WITH A LOT ABOUT
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
AND ONE MOMENT WE DO HAVE ONE
MORE LINE.
PLEASE TO ONE IS
ZERO. YES ONE MOMENT. I'M
TRYING TO LEARN THE LINE TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I GOOD
MORNING- THIS IS WHERE THE
DAMAGE SOME MORE OF THE-
SPEAKERS SO IN SUPPORT OF THE-
THE BILL- CAN- I MY NAME IS A
PLAN TO GO MISSING THE CHIEF
RANGER WITH YOU MOUNTAINS
RECREATION CONSERVATION
AUTHORITY. THANK YOU SENATORS
AND ALSO FOR ACQUIRING- THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE AND I CENTER
STERN AND MANY FOR A- THE TIME
TO. LISTEN TO THIS ABOUT EQUAL-
ELEMENT IS GOING TO BE
HAPPENING FOR YOU. AGAIN WOULD
YOU PREFER THE MRCA I AM A
PRODUCT THE STATE OF THE
INVESTMENT OF THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FOR THE UNDER IN
AREAS- AND WHEN I STARTED MY
CAREER- AS A TEENAGER. I WORKED
FOR THE LOS ANGELES
CONSERVATION CORPS. IN A
PROGRAM CALLED BEGINNING GREEN
PROGRAM WHICH OPENED THIS
OPPORTUNITY FOR ME TO BECOME-
WHERE I'M AT NOW STEP AND
STONE- AND I MEAN THAT. WE CAN
LEARN WITH HIS WORK. WELL CAN
BUILD BILL THE WORKING
COMMUNITY. THAT I WAS LIVING IN
THAT OTHER I WOULD NOT A PASCAL.
AND GOING THIS THE MOST. THERE
NOW. BOB IN A UP LAW. FOR A-
WORK COURT. WE AGAIN AND THAT
ACCORDING TO THE OFFICE YOU CAN
PROGRAM NOT. A CHOPPER. WAS
FUNDED BY TIME ONE MY-
CONSERVANCY. WHICH TAUGHT I.
NOW SKILLS IN THE- NOW THAT
INTRODUCED A IT WAS INTRODUCED
ME TO THE SKILL. AND THE WORK
OF THE WORLD. I WHICH I WAS
CAPTURE BY WHAT PARK RANGERS
DID AT THE TIME AND AGAIN GOT
THAT WELL. WE COME A PARK
RANGER. AND I APPLIED IN THE
MOUNTAINS RECREATIONAL
CONSERVATION AUTHORITY.
BECOMING THE FIRST RANGER
TRAINING. PROGRAM AND THE
PROGRAM WITHOUT HAVING. COMING
WITH PUBLIC RECORDS COLLEGE IN
THE OUT OF THE EXPERIENCE WHICH
I GET A LATER ON IF IN FOLKLORE
THE YEAR. BUT THAT OPPORTUNITY
THIS WORK FOR SPOKE PROGRAM.
BOB WOULD NOT BEEN YOU KNOW
WHERE I'M AT NOW BECAUSE OF
THESE PROGRAMS. AND I'M A FIRM
BELIEVER. HE'S RAIMES ALL HAVE
RALLIED TO THE THAT ARE. WOULD
BE BLOCKED OR- BECAUSE OF THE
DIFFERENT. OR WHAT THEY CALL
FROM. OUR BORN RAISED ON
ANGELES WHILE WORKING AS- WILL
OUT LINK. OPENED AROUND LIKE A.
BUT NO JUST FOR ANOTHER AND THE
OPPORTUNITY WORK ONES THAT
ACTUALLY ME WHERE I'M AT NOW
GET NOW THAT SHE RANGER THE MRI
A- AND I BELIEVE THE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS VERY VERY
VALUABLE THANK. WILL A LOT OF
HOW WORK FROM AND FROM THEN.
BUT WE WOULD BE EVER HAVE TO
SUFFER WITHOUT THE USE PROGRAM
SO I'M OUT YOU KNOW BY ASKING
YOU WHEN AGENCIES SIR USED TO
OUR CORPORATE YOU WORK FOR
DEVELOPMENT. TO THE FRONT OF
YOU KNOW YOU ARE. THE CAREER TO
THE- ON OF THE THANK OF THE- OR
HAVE WE ASK TO THEM CLIMB
RESILIENCE. IT'S IMPORTANT
THANK YOU CREATE A VARIETY OF
TYPES JOBS. THAT IS WHY IT.
ANSWER YOU HAVE SO APPOINTMENTS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CHIEF FOR
GOMEZ. FOR YOU SERVE AND YOUR
TESTIMONY. I THINK THAT IS IT
FOR A- IN SUPPORT MODERATOR TO
ANYONE ELSE IN Q. THEY'RE NOT
FOR COMMENTS IN Q. OKAY VERY
GOOD- IN THAT CASE LET'S MOVE
TO- ANY WITNESSES WE HAVEBEEN
HERE IN OPPOSITION- BEGINNING
IN FORTY TWO OR THREE. SEEING
NONE ROOM TWENTY FORTY. ALSO
SEEING NONE GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE MODERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANY- WITH THIS IS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN.
OPPOSITION ALL THOSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
OF SB TWELVE NINETY SIX PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF SB
TWELVE NINETY SIX PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THERE
ARE NO COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE.
OKAY THEN I WOULD JUST SAY TAKE
IT ALL OUR SUPPORT WITNESSES
AND BRING DISCUSSION BACK TO
MEMBERS I KNOW SENATOR WAY SO
YOU HAD A COMMENT OR QUESTION
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
JUST WANTED TO- MAKE COMMENTS
HERE- AND I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
MEASURE FORWARD. THIS THIS
MEASURE. IS THIS MEASURE FITS
VERY WELL VERY COMPREHENSIVELY
IN TERMS OF- ADDRESSING MANY
ISSUES THAT THE STATE IS
DEALING WITH I RECENTLY READ AN
ARTICLE IN THE NEW YORK TIMES.
THAT MENTIONED THERE WERE SEVEN
POINT SEVEN MILLION YOUNG
PEOPLE UNEMPLOYED AN AMERICAN
MADE REFERENCE TO THE
CONSERVATION CORPS BEING ONE OF
THE MECHANISMS THAT WAS
UTILIZED DURING THE GREAT
DEPRESSION TO GET SO MANY
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK AND OTHER
CARP CONSERVATION CORPS OF
CORPS PARTICULAR WAS USED TO
GET YOUNG PEOPLE. BACK TO WORK
AND- I'M JUST VERY GLAD TO SEE
A BILL LIKE THIS IS INTENDED.
TO NOT ONLY ADDRESS SOME OF OUR
STATES NEEDS. BUT TO GET PEOPLE
BACK TO WORK AND TO PUT A AND
TO REFERENCE. THE CONSERVATION
CORPS IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
LOCAL CORES. IN A AND I
SPECIFICALLY LOOK AT THE BILL
TO MAKE SURE. THAT THE LOCAL
COURTS ARE ALSO MENTIONED THAT
THEY WILL BE PART OF THE- OF
THE FRAMEWORK OF DELIVERY OF
SERVICES AND THEY WILL BE
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE. US FOR THE
CONTRACTS AND FUNDING ON THE
ATTENTION PROVIDED. RIGHT NOW
THROUGH THIS CRISIS MANY OF
THEM ARE ARE ARE STRUGGLING AS
MANY NONPROFITS ARE. BUT THESE
IN PARTICULAR SUITS SEWER OF A
LARGE PERCENTAGE OF THE
POPULATION IS CURRENTLY.
UNEMPLOYED AND IN NEED OF AN
EDUCATION WHICH IS OF THE
THINGS THAT THEY BALK TODAY.
THEY PROVIDE THE MOST HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMAS. A GOOD PAYING
JOB. AM I AM SKILLS THAT THEY
CAN UTILIZE FOR THE REST OF
THEIR LIVES IN AND GOOD PAYING
JOBS. SO WANTED TO MENTION
THAT- SUPPORT TO BUILD LIKE TO
MOVE THE BILL TO APPROPRIATE
TIME VERY GOOD MISTER CHAIR AND
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
REALLY CRITICAL. THANK CENTER
WAY SO IF YOUR COMMENTS- ON ANY
OTHER MEMBERS YES CENTER COPIER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR I AM. I ALSO WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR THIS
BILL I HAD SOME CONCERNS AND MY
BIGGEST CONCERN WAS WE WERE AT
THE TEN CONSERVANCY'S ON THAT
WERE LISTED IN HERE WHERE THEY
WERE LOCATED BECAUSE ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES AND IN MY DISTRICT
IS- AND FRANKLY WHEN YOU LOOK
AT STATE PARKS INVESTMENTS-
VERY FEW OF THEM ARE IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND- AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. BOB
WAR IN RURAL AREAS- THE CAN TO
BE HEAVILY CONCENTRATED ALONG
THE COAST REGION FOR OBVIOUS
REASONS BUT BUT THEN WHEN YOU
START TALKING ABOUT FUNDING
THOSE THEN THE MONEY GOES TO
WAIT FROM. ARE REALLY NEED THEM
AND SO- I APOLOGIZE I STEPPED
OUT TO TAKE A CALL THAT I'D
BEEN MISSING FOR DAYS AND I'M
AYE HE HAD HEARD FROM STOP IT
WE'RE TAKING THE COMMITTEE THE
SUGGESTED COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
AND SO I THINK THAT MAY TAKE
CARE OF THE ISSUE BECAUSE IS A
PROVISION IN ONE OF THE
SUBSECTIONS THAT. THAT THE
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD
COORDINATE WITHIN SIX SUPPORT
OF REGIONS OF THE STATE BUT
COVERED BY STATE CONSERVANCY
I'VE BEEN TRYING TO GET-
CONSERVANCY IN DISTRICT IN ONE
IT STAYS AT HIS LITTLE HAPPENED
BUT IN THE MEANTIME I'M SURE
THAT BIRDS DO YOU. AND I LADY
FOR THOSE TEN. LIST ARE. AND
JUST KNOW THAT ICE YOUTH
TRAINING I THINK THE REAL AND-
WELL I KNOW THAT THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD WILL COVER.
ANY AREA THAT'S NOT COVERED BY
OF A CONSERVANCY UP BECAUSE WE
DO WANT TO MAKE SURE AND I
TOTALLY AGREE WITH YOU THE
SENATOR- THAT- COMMUNITIES GET
LEFT OUT ON MANY DIFFERENT
LEVELS AND- AND HE SAID HE
DIDN'T WANT TO DO THAT SO WE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE WE
EXPLICITLY ASKED TO MAKE SURE
THAT RULERS WOULD BECAUSE SO
THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD
WILL COVER. YOUR AREA WELL
THAT'S GREAT I- I DID
APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY FROM-
RANGER GOMEZ. IT IT IS MORE
LIKELY THAT A YOUNG INDIVIDUAL
IS GOING TO BE ABLE TO TAKE THE
TRAINING NEAR THEIR HOME THEN
IT AS OPPOSED TO HAVING TO
TRAVEL SOMEWHERE ELSE THAT
THEY'RE JUST NOT THE MONEY. FOR
HOUSING AND ALL OF THE COSTS
INVOLVED IN MOVING BUT- I DO
SUPPORT THE BILL AND-
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS BECAUSE THAT THAT
THAT TAKES CARE THE CONSIDER
THE CONCERNS I HADN'T TURNED TO
RURAL RURAL COMMUNITIES. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR ANY OTHER
MEMBERS. QUESTIONS COMES UP
BRIEFLY PYLON- WITHIN MINUTES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR VISION AND
FOR. ELEVATING A CONSTITUENCY
THAT IS LEFT BEHIND TOO OFTEN
BUT IS ACTUALLY THIS CENTRAL
EQUITY HOLDER IN THIS WHOLE
PUZZLE IF WE'RE ACTUALLY GONNA
SOLVE ALL THESE CRISES. IT HAS
TO COME FROM THE COMMUNITY THE
STEWARDS IN WHATEVER PLACE THEY
LIVE AND THE- MAKE PEOPLE FEEL
LIKE STRANGERS IN THEIR OWN
LAND AND DIDN'T ISOLATE THEM
NOT JUST FROM OTHER BUT ALSO
FROM THEIR NATURAL RESOURCES IS
REALLY- A WASTE OF HUMAN
POTENTIAL IN THIS STATE- I READ
THE SAME ARTICLE CENTER HUESO
AND- YOU KNOW IT IT HARKEN BACK
TO- THE THIRTIES IN THIS
COUNTRY AND- AND A TIME THEN
WERE THERE WAS THE THREAT OF A
LOST GENERATION. AND
PRESERVATION LAUNCH THE
CONSERVATION CORPS. MEN THEY
PLANTED BILLIONS OF TREES AND
PUT A WHOLE GENERATION TO WORK
IN. THE NIGHT I FRANKLY THINK
THAT- WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING
REALLY BIG RIGHT NOW I DON'T
THINK WE CAN AFFORD TO DO
SOMETHING INCREMENTAL I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU'VE- YOU'VE
SORT OF. ACCEPTED THAT
CHALLENGE IN A WAY AND REALLY
TRIED TO EXPAND THIS TO MAKE IT
STATE WIDE TO HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE VISION I THINK.
EVEN IF YOU ALL LOOK AT THE
SCOPE OF THE PROJECTS- DON'T
JUST THINK OF THIS AS A TREE
ARMY- WHICH WE DO NEED TO
TACKLE THE THREAT OF CLIMATE
CHANGE AND- ALL THE HEAT ISLAND
EFFECT THAT IMPOSE BUT- THIS IS
ALSO ABOUT DISASTER RECOVERY
IN. AND RISK THIS IS ABOUT-
DEALING WITH THE IMPACTS OF THE
DROUGHT. OR WILD FIRES THESE
ARE ALL VERY REAL THINGS AND I
THINK IN ALL HIGH SCHOOLERS WHO
JUST WENT THROUGH THEIR
GRADUATION CEREMONIES AND MAYBE
LOOKING AT THE FUTURE NOT
KNOWING WHERE THE BRIDGES- THIS
IS THE YEAR TO BUILD THAT I
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT YOU KNOW
UNFORTUNATELY. GIVEN THAT. THE
DIFFICULT IN THE BUDGET IS A
POLICY BILL BUT THE COMMUNITY
ACCESS AND NONPROFIT FUNDING
THAT WAS SET ASIDE FROM THE
BOND IN SIXTY EIGHT WAS CUT
FROM THE BUDGET. AND I THINK
YOU KNOW WE HAVE A BOND
PROPOSAL IN THE SENATE AND WE
MOVED OUT OF OUR HOUSE- THAT
THAT. WOULD FIND EXACTLY THIS
KIND OF WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM AND I JUST. REGARDLESS
OF WHAT HAPPENS WITH FUNDING
THIS YEAR I THINK IT'S CRUCIAL
TO ARCHITECT THE VISION AND
SAID AND- I REALLY LAY OUT SOME
HOPE FOR YOUNG PEOPLE SO- AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME I'D LOVE
TO BE ADDED ON AS A CO AUTHOR
TO THE MEASURE- AND LOOK.
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU AS
THIS GOES FORWARD I APPRECIATE
THE DIVERSITY OF THE COALITION
YOU BUILT TO REALLY STRETCHING
BEYOND JUST LA AND- WE KNOW OUR
NEEDS ARE HUGE BUT- THEY'RE
THEY'RE EVERYWHERE SO THANK YOU
SENATOR AS ALL OF YOU TO CLOSE.
YOU KNOW I THIS CAME TO ME
BECAUSE I WAS OUT YOU KNOW
WITH. PEOPLE AND MEETING PEOPLE
WITH FRIENDS OF THE LA RIVER
AND THE NEW STATE HISTORIC
PARK. AND THEN I HAD VISITS
FROM. HIGH SCHOOL KIDS AND- IN
A COUPLE. KIDS I WAS LIKE. WHY
CAN'T. HAVE A- NOW JUST A SOME
JOB. YOU KNOW TO FILL IN THEIR
TIME. ONE SUMMER TWO SUMMERS
YOU KNOW ALL THIS GIVE THESE
POOR KIDS. YOU KNOW SUMMER JOBS
LIKE WHY NOT HAVE A REAL CAREER
WHY CAN'T THEY ENVISIONED
THEMSELVES AS A- ENVIRONMENTAL
IS FOR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
WORKING CLASS AND POOR
COMMUNITIES AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES. SO THAT'S WHAT
MOTIVATED ME. THEN YOU KNOW.
THE EXPERTS TURNED IT INTO A
BILL BUT THAT'S WHAT MOTIVATED
ME SO I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS AND- AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I URGE IN MY
BOOK. THANK YOU AND WE DO HAVE
A MOTION FOR. HUESO THIS. BILL
WILL BE THE MOST. IS I BELIEVE
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS- SO WITH THAT
SHE CONSULT WOULD YOU MIND CALL
THE ROLL. MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
STERN. HI EARN ALL RIGHT JONES
HI BILLS HI ALLEN. ALLEN ALL
RIGHT COVER EURO HI. CABALLERO
AYE HERTZBERG. FIVE HERTZBERG
HIGHWAY SO. HUESO AYE JACKSON
MONNING EINE LEARNING HI SEVEN
ZERO THAT'S A VERY GOOD THAT
THAT MEASURES OUT THANK YOU
SENATOR US I THINK. ALRIGHT
MOVING ON. WHAT I THINK WE'RE%
GONNA GO TO SENATOR MONNING IF
YOU'RE IF YOU'RE READY UNLESS
THERE'S NO I'M ON CONSENT SORRY
YOUR AYE CONSENT ME. I'M IN THE
HOT SEAT VERY GOOD MISTER. MR
FROM HER CHAIR I'M GONNA.
CAREFULLY SEN THE GAVEL TO YOU
DO ALWAYS WANT TO DO A- DO A
WILL DO A WIFE OFF ON HERE.
RIGHT SYMBOLICALLY PUTTING IT
IN YOUR PURVIEW VERY GOOD.
RIGHT. THEY. THANK. YEAH AND.
YEAH YEAH THEY WERE AS. AS
CENTER STERN WELCOME AND- YOU
ARE PRESENTING SB. THIRTEEN
FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU I MISTER
VICE CHAIR AT THANK YOU MEMBERS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT-
ABILITY STANDS REALLY FROM THE
WORKING GROUP THAT THE PRO
TEMAS CONVENE ON WILD FIRES-
AND I WANT TO THANK. ALL
MEMBERS OF THAT THAT WORKING
GROUP FOR THEIR INPUT IN THE
PROCESS- THE BILL IS QUITE
PERSONAL IT IT IT'S TECHNICAL
TOO BUT- IT GETS DOWN TO. THE
REASON PEOPLE LOSE EVERYTHING
IN OUR WILD FIRES AND- SOME
SEEMINGLY VERY BASIC AND SIMPLE
THINGS THAT WE SHOULD BE DOING
THAT WE JUST CAN'T. FIND A WAY-
TO DO EITHER AN INDIVIDUAL
BASIS- TO COMMUNITY BASIS AND
AS A RESULT WE HAVE A CRISIS IN
NOT JUST WILD FIRES
INVULNERABILITY BUT ALSO IN THE
INSURANCE MARKETS AND THAT SORT
OF GENERAL RISK. CLIMATE THAT-
IS INTOLERABLE IT'S A BUDGET
RISK TO WE MAY GET BLIND SIDED
pEVEN LATER THIS YEAR. AND NOT
BE ABLE TO MITIGATE THAT RISK
UP FRONT- BUT THE IRONY IS THAT
IT IT REALLY DOES COME DOWN TO
THOSE VERY SIMPLE PERSONAL
THINGS AROUND DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
IN THAT ZERO TO FIVE FEET
AROUND YOUR HOME IN YOUR NEARBY
COMMUNITY. AND THAT SORT OF A
NICHE THAT THAT HOME IGNITIONS
OWN THAT WE KNOW IS REALLY THE
EPICENTER OF RISK IN OUR NEW
WILL BE NOT SO MUCH IN THE
DEEPER RURAL AREAS BUT REALLY
THOSE OF YOU WHO LIVE. IN THOSE
NEARBY HILLSIDE COMMUNITIES
THAT EVENT THAT IS NOT GAS GET
IT RIGHT BACK GARAGE DOOR THAT
MISS A LITTLE BIT OF TAPE- THAT
BAD SHINGLE OR THAT BELIEVE
THAT ISN'T PROPERLY MAINTAINED.
THOSE ARE THE LITTLE THINGS.
THAT DO ALL THE DAMAGE- SO
WE'RE TRYING TO TIGHTEN UP THE
CODE HERE AND REALLY ALSO- MAKE
SURE CAL FIRES PROCESS WE'RE
FOR. THE BULK OF FUNDING IS
REALLY SLOWING IN THE STATE FOR
VERY MISSION MANAGEMENT IS THIS.
AWAY IT'S KIND AHEAD SERVE AND
THAT'S WE APPRECIATE THE SPEED
WITH WHICH WINNER. THESE
PROJECTS OR- IF LOOK AT THE MAP.
IT TENDS TO BE A VERY BIG TREE
CENTRIC EIGHTY WELL I'M A WE
KNOW IT FOURTH WE HAVE HUGE
HUGE RISK- IN THOSE. CROWN
FIRES BEING HEAVY WEIGHT WILD
FIRES THAT. COSTS PARADISE AND
SO MANY OTHER PROJECT BUT ALSO
NOTE- IN THE SHOWER. IN THE
FEDERAL SYSTEM YOU. CAN VALLEY
HILL. AND OUT CITY WILD SEVEN
THREE SIX AND READ. MEANT THE
SHAPE AND THE FACT. THAT NOW SO.
WE ARE. FOR ON A PLAN TO VERY
ABOUT THAT. THAT WILL SIR OF
FIRE SCAPE BUT NOW THESE OUT.
TENANTS OF WE CAN'T STILL GET
HOME HARD FUND OFF THE GROUND
AND WE STILL WE SORT OF LEFT
PEOPLE BEHIND IN THAT REGARD
THIS BILL IS HOPEFULLY AN
EFFORT FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
SPEAK UP AND TRY TO REMEDY SOME
OF THAT- THERE'S SOME SOME
IMPORTANT PROVISIONS ALSO
AROUND. A VACANT LOTS BEING
INCLUDED IN DRIVEWAYS AND
ROADWAYS- BUT ALSO YOU KNOW
WE'RE LOOKING AT BUILDING
STANDARD UPGRADES AND I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS BUT-
THAT'S THE ESSENCE OF THE
MEASURE- WE HAVE PACIFIC FORCED
TRUSTS PAUL MASON WITH US AS
WELL AS LOSE FORSBERG OUT WITH
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY WHICH
REALLY HELPED US. HONE IN A
FIVE SIGNS HERE AND SOMETIMES
IT'S- ITS ITS DECEPTIVELY
SIMPLE THE FIGHT BUT IT'S HOME
BY HOME BY HOME BY HOME IT
UNTIL WE IS COMMUNITIES CAN
HARDEN. THE INSURANCE MARKET
WON'T COME BACK THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO CERTIFY AS HOME BY
HOME SO IT'S HOW TO MARSHAL THE
COLLECTIVE ENERGY THAT I WISH
FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY ON SB
THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
SIR IS VERY WITNESSES- YOU
DON'T HOME ON THE SHEET OR THEY
ARE HERE TO JUST ANSWER
QUESTIONS OR THE- ON THE LINE
TO THEY CAN. THEY THEY CAN BE
YOUR FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
AND THEN I BELIEVE THEY ARE ON
THE LINE SO- TO DO WE WILL GIVE
THEM A MOMENT TO. MAKE THEM UP
YEAH WILL HAVE THE MODERATE
THEY CAN OFFER A MINUTE EACH
RIGHT THANK YOU. THE MODERATOR
CAN ALLOW THE MAIN WITNESSES TO
TESTIFY. THANK YOU CONSERVATIVE
AREAS THAT ARE TESTIFYING IN
FAVOR OF SB THIRTEEN FORTY
EIGHT. THIS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT TIME AND WE DO HAVE MIND
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THE TECHNICALLY
NOT MONDAY WITH FANDANGO
CAPTAIN ONLINE SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. TE MILLION
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT
JUST A MOMENT NINE FORTY FOUR.
THANK GOD. MORNING MORNING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF GLOBAL
CONSERVATION CORPS SUPPORT.
THANKS AND NINE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORNING CENTER
UPON A SLOW DESCENT FOREST'S
TRUST. SB THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT-
REALLY APPRECIATE STARNES
WILLINGNESS TO DIG INTO ALL THE
DETAILS ON THE- THIS COMPLEX
ISSUE I BET HE NOTED THIS BILL
IS A LITTLE BIT OF A
SMORGASBORD OF DIFFERENT POLICY
SOLUTIONS. AND MANY OF THEM ARE
JUST BANDS THE MARKET OUT THERE
FOR A LONG TIME BECAUSE THERE
ARE SOMEWHAT CALENDARING SUCH
AS YOU KNOW HOW DO WE WILL. AND
HONEST. TO BECOME THE HEARING.
MAY ISSUES AND HELP VERY MUCH
SB THIRTY EIGHT APPRECIATE A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF THIS ISSUE
ENTERED YOUR SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. NINE SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MEDICARE AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE GOOD
MORNING MY NAME AT THE BOTTOM.
AND YOUR CONSERVANCY WE JUST
WANT TO MAKE A COUPLE COMMENTS.
HE THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT MAKES
AND CHANGE TO IMPROVE COOLEY
ENERGY AND- FUTURE CRIME THAT
FIRE AREA. OF THE MONTH AND
CALIFORNIA'S ALL AND WE THAT
THIRTY FORTY EIGHT FURTHER
STRUCTURE AND. AROUND THAT
ALLOW IT GOT QUITE. AND ON
NATIONAL COURT. OF WORKING IN A
THAT ARE. HIGHER AREAS WE MUST
THEM MORE. WE CAN WORK REALLY
REQUIRES A BILL SANDERS. BASED
THAT. PLANNING AN PREVENTION OF
HIM BECAUSE- AND WE CAN THIS
BILL MAKES IMPORTANT NOT JACK.
THANK YOU. AND NINE FORTY TWO
YOUR LONG IS. GOOD MORNING
NUMBER OF THE CAN THAT VALERIE
CAROLINE BY HER. ON BEHALF OF
PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC
COMPANY IN COLLEGE. NINE TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MALE LEYVA I AM CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF THOUSAND
OAKS AND STRONG SUPPORT OF AT
EIGHT THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT. NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU ALL
THOSE WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT IN
FAVOR OF SB THIRTEEN FORTY
EIGHT. PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME TO OFFER COMMENTS.
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS FUND IN
FAVOR OF SB THIRTEEN FORTY
EIGHT PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU
MODERATOR LET'S MOVE BACK TO
OUR ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE
FOUR COMMENTS IN FAVOR OF SB
THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT. A MISTER
VICE CHAIR AND CHAIR CHRIS
MCKINLEY ON BEHALF OF HUMBLED
MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANIES
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY OTHER
COMMENTS IN FORTY TWO OR THREE.
WE CAN GO TO ROOM TWELVE FORTY.
NO COMMENTS IN TWENTY FORTY WE
KIND OF WENT ON ORDER SO MANY
GIVE THE MODERATOR ONE MORE
CHANCE ON COMMENTS IN SUPPORT
ON THE TELEPHONE. FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT
IN FAVOR OF SB THIRTEEN FORTY
EIGHT PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS. THEY'RE NOT FOR THE
COMMENTS IN THE- FAVOR OF
THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT THANK YOU
MODERATOR ANY COMMENTS IN FORTY
TWO OH THREE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT. AND WE'LL
GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY. NO
COMMENTS THERE AND ON THE PHONE
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN ASK FOR-
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO
THIRTEEN FORTY. FORTY EIGHT
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONCE AGAIN FOR ALL OF
THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO COME IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN FORTY
EIGHT PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE IN COMMON
CAN OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN
FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
MODERATOR WELL I GUESS WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE DíAS FOR-
COMMENTS ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS
THAT WISH TO SHARE A SINNER
BEARABLE AND THEN CENTER MONEY.
SENATOR STERN THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD IT IS
OBVIOUSLY A- AN ISSUE THAT WE
DESPERATELY NEED TO TACKLE- ARE
WILDFIRE RISK GOES UP EVERY
YEAR. AND WE'VE PLACE PEOPLE
ARE WE'VE ALLOWED PEOPLE TO
BUILD IN AREAS THAT WE PROBABLY
SHOULDN'T HAVE QUITE FRANKLY SO
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
DEAL WITH IT AFTER THE FACT
BECOMES A CHALLENGE BUT- I AM I
WANT TO MAKE SURE I. I
UNDERSTAND IT IF THERE IS A
BUNCH OF MOVING PIECES SO- I
APOLOGIZE IF THIS SEEMS
DISJOINTED BUT- BUT AS I WAS
READING THROUGH THE ANALYSIS- I
JUST WASN'T SURE EXACTLY WHAT.
SO WHAT I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND IS. WHAT ARE WE
GIVING WHAT AUTHORITY ARE WE
GIVING TWO DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS HOW. ARE RESIDENT
SUPPOSED TO RESPOND TO THIS ON
A FORTY AND THEN WHO'S PAYING
FOR IT RIGHT- AND ON AND ON
UNDER THE PROPOSED A LOT. THE
LINE UNDER UNDER NUMBER. THREE
IT IT IT THE SENTENCE DOESN'T
SEEM TO MAKE SENSE TO ME AND I
HAVE TO ADMIT THAT USING A MASK
AND INHALING LIKE CARBON
MONOXIDE FOR FIVE HOURS ADULTS
OF THE BRAIN BUT WHEN IT SAYS
THAT THAT- THAT CAL FIRE CAN
DEVELOPING PROPOSED FOR THE
LEGISLATURE FOR CONSIDERATION A
FINANCIAL PENALTY STRUCTURE TO
APPLY TO LAND OWNERS. FOR WHOM
THE DIRECTOR HAS AUTHORIZED THE
REMOVAL OF VEGETATION IN
CONSISTENT WITH APPLICABLE
DEFENSE DEFENSIBLE SPACE
REQUIREMENT AND IS MADE THE
EXPENSE OF THE REMOVAL A LEAN
UPON THE PROPERTY IS PROVIDED
SO. HOW CAN READ IT HOW CAN.
THE DIRECTOR AUTHORIZE THE
INCONSISTENT WITH UP- I SEE I
GET IT WELL JUST NEED TO READ
IT LIKE TEN TIMES SO MY CAN MY
CONCERN IS THIS- CAL FIRE SAYS
THE THESE ARE THE TREES IT NEED
TO BE REMOVED HERE'S THE BRUSH
YOU NEED TO GET RID OF AND THEY
LOCAL COUNTY ORDINANCE SAYS
THOU SHALT NOT TAKE OUT ANY
TREES THAT WE DON'T. GIVE YOU
PERMISSION TO SO HOW DOES IT
WORK WITH. WITH THAT THE- THOSE
CHALLENGES WHERE. YOU KNOW
LOCAL ENTITIES WANT TO BE ABLE
TO KEEP. AT BOTH NUMBER ONE
LOCAL ENTITIES BUT TO THERE'S
THIS POLICY OF. BEING GREEN AND
THE GREEN IS MORE TREES AND-
AND TAKING. CARBON OUT OF THE
AT THE CARBON SAID
SEQUESTRATION. IF YOU COULD IF
YOU COULD ADDRESS THAT- AND
THEN. THE. THE OTHER PART OF IT
IS. WHERE DOES THE MONEY COME
FROM. AND I HAVE A HARD TIME
QUITE FRANKLY NOW THAT WE'RE
DOING BUDGETS. TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE PRIORITIZE PEOPLE
TAKING OUT TREES THAT ARE THAT
LIVE IN WEALTHY NEIGHBORHOODS
THAT HAVE THE WHERE WITH ALL
AND WE DO A GRANT PROGRAM SO WE
CAN TAKE THAT STUFF OUT INSTEAD
OF PUTTING MONEY INTO SOCIAL
SERVICES OR INTENT HEALTH
THEIR- HEALTHCARE THAT KIND OF
THING SO IF YOU COULD TALK TO
BOTH OF THOSE ISSUES I- UPS OF
COURSE. TO THE VISION YOU WERE
REFERRING TO IS A- IS A STUDY
IN PROPOSED KIND OFPROVISION
IT'S NOT A ACTUAL ENACTMENT OF
ANY PENALTY STRUCTURES I THINK
THE WAY IT'S DRAFTED IT. HERE'S
TO WOULD BE UP FULL. DEFENSIBLE
SPACE CODE IS SO THAT WOULD.
DELEGATE DOWN DATE TO COUNTIES
SO IF COUNTIES HAD. YOU YOU YOU
SINCE SOME KIND OF THIS ALREADY
EXISTS RIGHT. OKAY THAT'S HOW
THE ADMINISTERED I THINK THE
IDEA WOULD BE IS THERE IS THERE
SOME OTHER STRUCTURE THAT CAL
FIRE WANTS TO COME UP WITH THE
OFFER TO THE COUNTIES. AS SOME
KIND OF ENFORCING MECHANISM BUT
WE DON'T. YOU ONLY HAVE TO
CROSS THE BRIDGE WITH THIS OF.
STUDYING AT CONS NOT
NECESSARILY AN ACTING IT BUT I.
THE NUYS THAT THAT TO END IT IS
VERY MUCH. ALL TO ME TWO IS
WHEN THEY COME KNOCKING YOUR
DOOR MAY YOU CAN'T THE LAN. YOU
CAN'T GET THROUGH IT OR YOUR
YOU CAN BLOCK FOR OTHER
REASONS- BUT I KNOW CENTER
BONDING IS SIMPLER CONCERNS IN
THEIR COMMUNITY WHERE. YOU GOT
A PROJECT YOU WANT TO DO WHICH
AGAIN BLOCKED FOR SOME REASON
SO I APPRECIATE THAT
SENSITIVITY BUT THAT'S THE
GENERAL STRUCTURE IS A- LOCAL.
LOCAL ORDINANCES TO BE TAKEN
INTO ACCOUNT WE DO NEED TO
CLARIFY THAT THOUGH IN THE IN
THE IT IN THE BILL I'M HAPPY TO
DO THAT AND THEN IN TERMS OF
THE- COURT. RIGHT NOW THERE IS
A MODEST AMOUNT I THINK IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR
DEFENSIBLE SPACE INSPECTION-
WORK- I WOULD SAY THAT PRIVATE
LANDOWNERS ARE STILL
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR OWN
PRIVATE PROPERTY SAID DIDN'T
EAT IT'S MORE TO MANAGE OUR
LIABILITY ON OUR PUBLIC LANDS
BUT ALSO. THE UNFORTUNATE
FEDERAL LANDS- ARE ONE OF THE
BIG ISSUES OUT THERE SO RIGHT
NOW CAL FIRE GRANTS ARE
ACTUALLY AUTHORIZED TO GO
SUBSIDIZE FEDERAL PLANS WHICH I
FURTHER CAN'T GET MY HEAD
AROUND. WE WANT TO WRITE IT UP
AND SORT OF ON THOSE AREAS. OF
FINANCIAL IN CAPACITY ALSO
SUPER RICH AND I THINK RIGHT TO
RAISE THOSE EQUITY CONCERNS I
THINK THAT'S GOT THE LANDS
WHICH WITH LOOK AT IT THIS. THE
WHILE THE ERROR RESERVE BON
DOES PROVISIONS IN IT THAT THAT
WOULD SORT OF ADD SOME FUNDING
STREAM TO THAT- BUT WE CAN TAKE
A CLOSER LOOK AT THIS SORT OF
EQUITY PIECE OF IT BECAUSE I
ALSO YOU KNOW I COME FROM ONE
OF THOSE COMMUNITIES IN MALIBU
RIGHT NOW WHO BURNED DOWN BUT
MALIBU ALSO THERE. IS THIS IN
HERE IN THERE YOU KNOW RETIRED
TEACHERS IN NURSING
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS BUT FOR
THE MOST PART. SENATE
INCREDIBLY WEALTHY COMMUNITY
THAT I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD
ACTUALLY BE SUBSIDIZING. THEIR
RISK GUY THERE SO AS AS I LOVE.
MY PEOPLE FACT OF THE INS FOR
THE- AROUND HOLDING MISSIONS ON
PRINCIPLES CAME FROM FRIENDS OF
MINE FOR MICE. WHO LOST THEIR
HOME THERE WAS A GARDEN HOSE
TRYING TO KEEP THEIR FRIENDS.
HOME UP IN YOU KNOW WE ALL LOST
A LOT THEN AND SO. I DISSED I
DON'T WANT THIS TO BE TOO
PRECIOUS AND IT'S GOT TO BE
FOCUSED ON TARGETED SO. LET'S
LET'S TAKE IT. WITH YOU AND
JUST MAKE SURE WHATEVER'S GOING
INTO A PROCS. HAS THAT SORT OF.
THAT AND- BECAUSE WE- ARE
THERE'S NO PROCREATION IN BILL.
IT THERE'S NO WAX. YEAH TING
SCHEMA AT THE IT'S MY SO ABOUT
THE BUILDING STANDARD PIECE.
AND REALLY THE CAL THE EXISTING
CAL GRANTS BELIEVE THERE'S
ABOUT TWENTY FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS MORE THAT'S ABOUT TO GO
OUT. TO REFINE THAT REALLY
FOCUS IT IN THESE AREAS THAT
HAVEN'T BEEN GETTING IT. SO
YEAH I JUST THINK THAT WITH
THEIR THAT AS WE STARTLOOKING
AT SOME OF THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE. CHANGE THAT WE ALSO
LOOK AT. LOS BURDEN THAT WE
SHOULD AWAY FROM PEOPLE THAT
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR RISK
RISK- LIKE BUILDING ON A CLIFF.
OVERLOOKING THE OCEAN AND YES
SALUTE YOU KNOW THEY GET
REIMBURSEMENT AND THAT THAT
KIND OF THING. BUT AND THEN SO
THE AND I JUST WANTED TO OPEN
THAT DISCUSSION BUT ON. ALSO IN
REGARDS TO THE TRIENNIAL
BUILDING CODE- THE BILL INTO
PAGE ONE YEAR TO GET THE- THE
WORK DONE AND I'M NOT SURE I
WOULD I WOULD ASK YOU TO CHECK.
IN WITH THAT BILL STANDARDS
COMMISSION. BECAUSE OF MY
EXPERIENCE AS A CHAIR OF THAT
ORGANIZATION FOR. A WHILE IT
TAKE I HAVE A LITTLE COMMENT ON
THAT SO WE'VE ACTUALLY BEEN.
GRAHAM VERY CLOSELY WITH BOTH.
THE FIRE MARSHAL BUILDING
STANDARDS SO I THINK THIS. IS A
IT. THIS IS. BUT IT'S ALL IT'S
A WITH THE FI CODE NOW THEY'RE
THEY'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
TRANSLATING SOME OF THAT OVER
TO THE BUILDING STANDARDS CAN
THAT'S WHAT HAS TO HAPPEN IS IT
HAS TO ALREADY BE IN SOMETHING
IN ORDER. TO GET TO THEM FOR
THAT YEAH NOTE THAT THE
APPRECIATE THE DETAIL HERE AND
I WOULD JUST SAY ON THAT
BUILDING INTO THE RISK ISSUE
LOOK WE'VE GOT TO HAVE A TOUGH
DEBATE THIS YEAR'S PURRS AS-
GOING INTO THE HOUSING
CONVERSATION. WE WANT TO SAY
YES. BE CAREFUL WHERE WE SAY
YES AND FRANKLY I MEAN I'VE GOT
CONCERNS ABOUT AROUND. JUST
THROWING NEW HOUSING UP IN IN
THESE. VERY NARROW CANYONS IN
AREAS WHERE. CAL FIRES ALREADY
SAID OR LOCAL AUTHORITIES ARE
SAID. THIS IS SUPER HIGH RISK
BUT YET. YOU KNOW YOU WANT THE
FANCY HOME UP THERE YOU WANT
FOR EVEN THE A DO YOU FRANKLY I
THINK WE'VE- TO BE. SORT OF.
EQUALLY RIGID ABOUT NEW GROWTH
INTO THE WILL BE SO I AGREE
WITH YOU THERE. AND HOPEFULLY
WE CAN. CLEAN UPS THE STAFF
DOES GO THROUGH THIS PROCESS TO
MAKE SURE WE DON'T. INCREASE
OUR LIABILITIES- SET. UP HERE
YEAH CEREMONY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I WANT TO THINK- CHAIR
STERN FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
IN IS YOUR REFERENCE WE TALKED
ABOUT SOME OF THIS EARLIER. I
DO AGREE WITH THE CONCERNS OF
MY CALLING SENATOR CAFIERO. SO
IN. IN A DISTRICT IT'S LARGELY
RURAL THAT I REPRESENT WE HAVE
INTERFACE OF SOME LARGE
POPULATIONS WITH WILD LANDS-
PRONE TO WILD FIRE CALPERS JUST
DECLARED IMAGE STARTED RAIN
SHOWERS THAT WE ARE OFFICIALLY
ANSWERING FIRE SEASON- SOME OF
THE RANGE WE AT EARLIER HAVE
JUST. FUELED GROWTH SOME OF
FUEL AREAS YOU MADE A
DISTINCTION BETWEEN TIMBER
REMOVAL IN THE SEARS AND SOME
OF OUR STATE WE'RE GOING INTO
FEDERAL LANDS I WOULD SHARE
YOUR CONCERN THAT. FEDERAL
DOLLARS SHOULD BE. DETECTING
FEDERAL LANCER DOING
APPROPRIATE CLEARANCE- THE SOME
OF THE AREAS THAT I REPRESENT.
HOMEOWNERS PROPERTY OWNERS HAVE
BEEN THWARTED IN TRYING TO JUST
BUILD THEIR OWN- BUT FOR SPACES
AROUND THEIR HOMES BECAUSE OF
PERMITTING REQUIREMENTS- EITHER
THE COUNTY OR THE STATE LEVEL
SO. I WOULD JUST SAYS THAT AS
YOU MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS WE
CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION
INTERESTED IN YOUR COMMENTS IF
YOU FACE THIS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BUT THOSE THAT WANT
TO SELF HELP TO PROTECT THEIR
PROPERTY AND THEIR NEIGHBORS.
CAN'T DO IT. AND SO WE'VE HAD
THE UNDER THE DECLARATION OF.
EMERGENCY AUTHORITY BY THE
GOVERNOR. OVER THE LAST YEAR-
THERE WERE A CERTAIN NUMBER OF
SITES THIRTEEN YEAR TWENTY
EIGHT OR THIRTY SIX SIR NUMBER
OF SITES AROUND THE STATE. FOR
PRIORITY. MAINTENANCE AND
CLEARANCE USING CAL FIRE CREWS
SOME OF THOSE WERE IN MONTEREY
COUNTY- BUT- IS STILL THE
PROBLEM I SEE HERE THAT I HEAR
ABOUT FROM CONSTITUENTS IS. WE
WANT TO CLEAR SPACE AND WE
CAN'T GET THE PERMITTING. BUT
SO. WE CAN WORK ON THAT
TOGETHER IS THIS MOVES FORWARD
WELCOME ANY COMMENTS YOU MIGHT
HAVE ON THAT. THANK YOU
CEREMONY- I HAVE A SHARE THE
SAME- ANECDOTAL EXPERIENCE AND
IN MY COMMUNITY AND- I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT- IN THE NEXT
ROUND OF FUNDING- AS WELL AS
THE ROLL OUT OF THEIR
VEGETATION. AND PROGRAM HOW
FIRES PROPOSED A BROADER
FRAMEWORK THAT AT- SOME
OPPOSITION AND- IS CURRENTLY
BEING LITIGATED- IN TERMS OF
WHAT OVERALL STATE PROGRAM. TWO
FOUR RATIONALIZE OUR STATE
SHE'S WITH. ISSUES IT IS AN
AREA FRAUGHT WITH PERIL I WOULD
SAY LOCAL AND TELL YOU IT IS
THE ONLY WAY TO GET THROUGH AND
REALLY HAVE IT BEING. WHEN I
TRY TO BROUGHT ONE. PLAN FOR
THE STATE. IS GOING TO BE
CRUCIAL SO THAT YOU KNOW. WE
HAVE WE'VE HAD A WERE DISASTER
COMING THERE'S A HILLSIDE IT'S
A BUT YOU THAT YOU'VE GOT A
CLEAR IT- AND THERE ARE
PROVISIONS UNDER CURRENT LAW
THAT THAT CAN BE WAIT- WHETHER
THEY'RE BEING EXERCISED IN A
SYSTEMATIC MANNER AND REALLY
DONE. WITH AN EYE FOR THAT HAVE
A TERRORIST NATION BUT BUT WITH
THE COPS EFFORT TO SAY. WE NEED
TO FIND SOME IN SOME THIRD PATH
HERE I THINK. WE GET. THE KINDS
OF PROJECTS YOUR TALK ABOUT THE
KINDS OF- CLEARANCES AND HOME
HARDENING. WE JUST CUT A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OUT OF
THE BUDGET FOR THAT PROGRAM- OR
WE DIDN'T THAT IT WAS PROPOSED
IN THE MAY REVISED- THE
GOVERNOR UP TO A PLAN FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE WRIT LARGE.
DAHLE SOME OF THE ISSUES. WE'VE
ALREADY GOT THAT ARE SENATE
BOND WE'VE GOTTA HOME
HARDENING- PLAN IN THERE SO I
THINK THAT THERE ARE PATHWAYS
TO GETTING THIS WORK DONE. BUT
THE CURRENT APPROACH AT LEAST
IS REALLY NOT AS FOCUSED ON
THOSE THAT RIGHT AROUND THE-
IT'S MUCH SO WAY LIKE FOR UNDER
THE WILD IT PREVENTING THOSE
MEGA FIRES AND SO. WE GOT. IT'S
NOT. WE GOT A- WE CAN'T BURNED
THE NORTH ELLEN LEAVE THE SOUTH
OR VICE VERSA AND WE'RE ALL IN
IT TOGETHER SO ANYWAY LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU IN
THE PROCESS AND- SHE THE
URGENCY ALL THIS. SO HABITS ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS. IT
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE IT MR STERN
YOU MAY CLOSE ON THIRTEEN FORTY
FOUR THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
TO. AS THE BULLS THE FIRE
SURVIVORS AND- PARADISE
SURVIVORS IN- ALL ALL KINDS OF
OTHER CONSTITUENTS AROUND THE
STATE WHO REALLY HELPED INFORM
THE BILL AND- TO LOOK. TO LOOK
RIGHT UNDER YOUR NOSE FOR WHERE
THE RISK IS LYING. IT'S A
DANGEROUS TEN DECEPTIVE WORLD
OUT THERE AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE
A HARROWING. EGGMAN PERIOD IS
NOT GOING TO BE AN EASY YEAR
AYE AYE YOU KNOW YOU DON'T WANT
TO- PORTEND ANY ILL BUT- THE
RAIN TIMING IS CENTER MINING
POINTED OUT AND THE DROUGHT
CONDITIONS WERE UNDER- IT
DOESN'T LOOK TO BE ANY BETTER
THAN LAST YEAR SO- THIS IS
NEEDED NOW MORE THAN EVER. TO
GET A JUMP START I APPRECIATE
YOUR CONSIDERATION PASS FOR
I'VE A- THANK YOU IS THERE A
MOTION. SOME OF THE MOTION MY
CENTER COME AERO IS THEM MMHM
THERE'S NO AMENDMENTS RIGHT THE
JUST PASS OUR MOVE TO APPROACH
IT SOME. MOTIONS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS. NINETY FIVE
FINAL CONCERNS NO IF THE A
CONSULTING FIRM PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND I'VE BEEN
REMINDED TO REMIND YOU MEMBERS
TO PLEASE TURN ON YOUR MIKES
WHEN YOU VOTE SO THAT THEY CAN
HEAR ON THE PHONES AND SUCH-
STERN. HI BURN ALL RIGHT JONES.
JONES NO ALLEN. ALLEN HI
CABALLERO HI KIRBY ERROL I
HERTZBERG I BIRDS. ALL RIGHT
MONNING HI. SIX ONE THAT. THAT
VOTERS TO ONE THAT BILL IS OUT
AND I WILL TURN THE- GAVEL BACK
TO THE CHAIR. VERY GOOD THANK
YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR I THINK
WE JUST HAVE WE JUST OF THE
LIVE CALLS ON SB TWELVE AND
THEN WE'RE GOING TO WRAP HERE I
THINK CENTER YEAR. STILL NEEDS
AN OPPORTUNITY ON THAT SHE- SO.
CHIEF SO WOULD YOU THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM ONE IS BE TEN TWELVE.
AGAIN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
APPROACH. CABALLERO HI. FEB
ZERO I'D JACKSON. SEVEN OH.
OKAY SO THAT IS SET OH THAT
BILL IS OUT DO WE ANY AND
ANYTHING LEFT ON CALL OKAY.
MEMBERS I THINK THAT IS IT. IRV.
WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR TEST MONEY
OR OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD SO
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND THANKS FOR
EVERYONE AND THEIR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION IF INCLUDING THE
AGENDA THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL RESOURCE AND WATER IS
HEREBY ADJOURNED.